stephen has reared these pigs for their
meat
he supplies a supermarket with high
welfare pork
but there aren't enough butchers to
process them
if the abattoir can't take them this
week they could be destroyed i think
it's the biggest waste and it's the
biggest mess caused by a government ever
in agriculture
in the life of this country the mind in
my lifetime it's just horrendous we went
through foot and mouth and that was bad
enough but this is nothing like foot and
mouth this is far far worse
the situation is getting critical for
every pig farmer in the uk
if the pigs get too big they aren't
simply worth less so for example from a
pig this size a pork chop wouldn't
actually fit into a supermarket tray
as well as that
pigs generally have to be reared indoors
and farmers are running out of space for
them so we can't just keep pushing more
pigs in a pen the welfare of the pig
comes first and they'll start fighting
and the pigs we just can't do that so
they will have to be shot and disposed
off and wasted i know of slotsmen have
been booked to go into east anglia next
week for 4 000 pigs and that's just just
the start of it and the mental anguish
and the
toll on farming families is just going
to be horrendous what will it do to you
to have someone come here to your farm
to shoot the pigs that you had reared
for meat
it's going to be so soul-breaking it's
just just not right and
it's not the financial cost we'll
weather that everybody's had to weather
costs through the pandemic and
everything it's it's the emotion
it's the thought of not being wanted by
government the only way i can see that
we can deal with this is to get the army
involved with disposal with killing and
army vets as well because the army does
have vets and we're going to have to
call them in to help
with no sign of help for the labor
market
farmers think 12 thousand pigs a week
could end up being slaughtered and
incinerated
lisa dowd sky news derbyshire